Hi, this is Unusual
Neurological
Diseases, Somatoform
Disorders,
and Factitious Disorders.
And I am Dr. Leder. I
am going to guide you
through these very
interesting conditions.
So the session
objectives today
are to distinguish
neurological
disorders from
psychiatric disorders.
Recognize when
psychiatric disease is
comorbid with
neurological disorders.
identify when a
patient is causing harm
to him or herself
and to implement
proper treatment for
these conditions.
So case one, a 60
-year-old woman is
struggling to get dressed.
While the right hand
is buttoning, the left
hand is unbuttoning.
Is this a neurologic
or a psychiatric
condition and what
is this called? What
condition would you
expect to see it in?
So this is alien
limb phenomenon.
It's seen in about
30 to 50 percent of
patients with a
neurodegenerative
condition called
corticobasal degeneration.
It can affect
the arm or leg.
The arm moves outside
of voluntary control
and is able to perform
a complex action.
The limb literally
can have a mind of
its own and very often
the opposing hand
needs to hold down
this alien limb. When
patients are walking
the arm might just
levitate by itself
and the patient very
often is unaware of
what the arm is doing.
Case two is a 56 year
old man who's brought
to the emergency room
by his family with
strange behavior. On
examination he has
difficulty following
your finger for the
cranial nerve exam and
he absolutely bombs
the visual fields.
He compliments you on
glasses that you're not
wearing. On the gait
exam, he walks into
the storage closet.
This is called Anton
syndrome. It's also
known as the Anton
Babinski syndrome, which
is visual anosognosia.
So there's denial of
vision loss with
associated confabulation to
mask the deficit. And
it's associated with
etiology to bilateral
occipital lobes, which
cause cortical
blindness. So everything
within their eyes is
fine. It's the part of
the brain that controls
vision that's being
affected. The patients
lack awareness of
their deficit. It is
a very rare condition.
However, if you're
interested in reading
about it, a patient has
this condition in the
book called The Insult
by Rupert Thompson.
Case 3 is a 17-year
-old girl who presents
with recent difficulty
in school. A
few months ago, she
had a flu-like illness.
First, her memory
became a problem,
and then she became
agitated, and she
was convinced that
the neighbors were
watching her. During
her examination, her
legs began moving in
a peddling motion,
and then she had a
generalized seizure.
So this is called
NMDAR encephalitis
and it is the focus
of first the book who
the author of the
book was actually a
reporter before she
developed this so
she wrote the book
Brain on Fire because
she experienced it
firsthand and this
book was actually
made into a movie.
This is an autoimmune
encephalitis. It
can be associated with
an ovarian tumor or
other rare tumors.
The patients initially
present with
neuropsychiatric symptoms.
Seizures can occur
that are resistant
to anti-epileptic
drugs, and the patients
may also present
with unusual movement
disorders. This may
be a perineoplastic
condition, and so
it's very important
to get a pelvic
sonogram in any
woman who presents
with this condition.
Case 4 is a 12-year
-old girl who's brought
to the clinic because
of difficulty walking.
It's currently a morning
appointment and the
parents claim that by
the evening she has
to be carried. Her
parents are perplexed
because she walks fine
in the morning. She is
not having difficulty
walking at this time.
This is a condition
called dopa-responsive
dystonia, and it's
also called Sagawa's
disease, or DIT5, or
DYT stands for dystonia
type 5. It presents
with a gait abnormality
that's due to lower
extremity dystonia. It
can be mistaken for
cerebral palsy or *******
dysplegia, and I
have met patients who
were actually wheelchair
-bound until they
were given levodopa.
Once they're given the
proper medication, they
could walk absolutely
normally. In this
condition, there's a
diurnal fluctuation,
which means that symptoms
are fine in the
morning when they wake
up, but then they
worsen in the afternoon.
Their levodopa
response is
remarkable and
stays low generally
throughout
their lifetime.
case 5 is a 20 year old
man who reports that
whenever he stands up
quickly the muscles
on the left side of his
body become extremely
tight it often causes
him to fall he has
difficulty reproducing
this in the office
this is paroxysmal
kinesiogenic dyskinesia
it's a dystonic posture
or dyskinesia, which
is brief and lasts
seconds to minutes. If
the clinician is not
well-versed in this
particular condition,
it's possible for the
patient to be misunderstood
and believed to
be making this up. These
attacks are triggered
by sudden voluntary
movements, stress,
startle, or sleep
deprivation, and they can
occur up to 100 times
a day in some cases.
In some patients,
seizures can also be
present. It often
responds to carbamazepine
or another anti
-seizure medication.
Case 6. A patient
is blindfolded and
given an object to
hold in his left
hand. He cannot name
the familiar object.
When it is transferred
to the right
hand, he is able
to name the object.
So this is called split
brain syndrome and
currently many of you
You may be watching
the Apple movie called
Severance, where
it seems as though
they split the people's
brains in half, but
that's not really what
it looks like. The
real split brain
syndrome is callosal
disconnection syndrome.
It is rare and the
result of a patient
who has a lesion
to the corpus
callosum. It could
be due to surgery,
a genesis of the
corpus callosum,
multiple sclerosis,
a ******, a
tumor, or Marchiofava
bignami disease.
The left hemisphere is
generally responsible
for calculations,
reading, and speech,
while the right
hemisphere deals with
spatial tasks. when
this when the corpus
callosum is severed
in some way that's
when the condition
described can be seen.
Case 7 is a 60 year
old man who's brought
to the emergency room
acutely confused.
His wife relates
that they were out to
dinner and suddenly
he began asking where
are we what's the
date over and over.
He's able to repeat
digit spans on exam.
This is called transient
global amnesia.
It is the acute onset
of anterograde amnesia
or the inability to
form new memories.
The patient repeatedly
asks the same
question and it reflects
the disorientation.
The other cognitive
functions are normal.
The patient eventually
returns to normal and
it's generally within
a 24-hour time span.
This condition
is presumed to
be because of
either migraine,
ischemia, epilepsy,
or psychogenic
in origin. It is
not clear what
the cause of this
condition is.
Case 8 is a 25-year-old
woman who is admitted
to the hospital
with high fever and
is found to have
endocarditis. On further
investigation, it's
determined that she
works in a microbiology
lab. She's found to
be infected with a
rare infectious agent.
Case 9 is a 27-year
-old woman who comes
into the clinic in
a wheelchair. She
brings a chart the size
of an encyclopedia,
and it's organized
with dividers.
She's seen every
doctor that you know
and has been to the
Mayo Clinic twice.
She suggests a
muscle biopsy because
it's the one
procedure she has
not managed to
have yet. She is
refusing to speak
to a counselor.
factitious disorder
is what occurs when
an individual
falsifies physical or
psychological signs
or symptoms or induces
injury or disease with
intended deception
both cases just
described are associated
with factitious
disorder the individual
can create signs or
symptoms by lying,
by putting drops
of blood into their
urine sample, are
actually creating disease
into themselves by
injecting bacteria.
The primary aim is
to achieve a patient
role, and the behavior
persists even in
the absence of monetary
rewards or drugs.
The individual may
seek an invasive
diagnostic test,
surgery, or a particular
treatment. There have
even been reports
of patients coming
to the emergency room
and feigning ******
in order to get TPA.
And there are other
cases similar to this.
So Munchausen syndrome
is the most severe
variant of factitious
physical disorder.
It is associated
with exaggerated
lying, is known
as pseudalgia
Fantastica,
sociopathic behavior,
geographic wandering
from hospital to
hospital, the patient
lives a continuous life
of patienthood, and they
may also use aliases
in order to get their
desired response.
Case 10 is a 12-year
-old girl who's missed
school again. She's
in another doctor's
office. She's extremely
thin, tired, and
weak. It's 4 p.m., and
her mother would not
allow her to eat all
day again. Mom is
about to suggest open
heart surgery to the
doctor and this is
called Munchausen's by
proxy. It's a form of
child ***** and elder
***** that could be
overlooked and the
caregiver is the one
who causes the sickness
in the person they're
taking care of.
As you can see I
enjoy reading some
these are a couple
of books that
are about
Munchausen's by proxy
More Than It Hurts
You by Darren Strauss
Sickened by Julie
Gregory and The
Angel of Darkness
by Caleb Carr
all deal with
Munchausen by proxy
Case 11 is a 22-year
-old woman who is
obsessed that her
thighs are extremely fat
and she comes to
the *** for medical
clearance before a major
fat trimming surgery
On examination, she
is in normal builds
and her legs are
proportionate but not
heavy. What condition
do you suspect?
This is called body
dysmorphic disorder.
BDD is characterized
by a preoccupation
with a perceived
defect or flaw in the
patient's appearance.
Generally, the
flaw is not observed
by others and the
patient becomes
obsessed with this
particular flaw. The
preoccupation triggers
repetitive behaviors
which are difficult
to control and are
not pleasurable.
case 12 is a 25 year
old woman from el
salvador who presents
to the ob-gyn clinic
she states that the
reason for her visit is
to establish care in
order to deliver her
baby she appears to
have a gravid abdomen
but after extensive
testing it is determined
that she is actually
not pregnant this
is called pseudosiesis
it's the false
belief that a patient's
that a patient is
pregnant, including a
growing abdomen, morning
sickness, and the
cessation of menses.
It is unclear if
this condition
is due to hormones
or in some
cases could be
psychiatric.
Case 13, a 26-year-old
woman is brought to
the hospital soon after
the death of a close
family member. A
friend who brought her
states she suddenly
became paralyzed. When
you ask her to walk,
she is an extremely
bizarre gait and nearly
falls but does not.
This is functional
neurological disorder.
Neurologic symptoms
such as weakness,
abnormal movements, or
non-epileptic seizures
without structural
disease. Clinical
findings on examination
are not compatible
with a recognized
neurologic disease.
The disorder causes
distress and or functional
impairment and has
a poor prognosis.
The patients need
psychological support and
often physical therapy
in order to improve.
Case 14 is a 20-year
-old woman who presents
to the emergency
room after a minor
motor vehicle accident.
She complains of
numbness down the left
side of her body. A
vibrating tuning
fork is placed on her
forehead. She insists
that she feels the
vibrations on the right
but not on the left.
This is actually
called malingering and
the patient consciously
creates physical
or psychological
symptoms to assume the
sick role with the
goal of receiving a
reward. The reward can
include money, insurance
settlement, drugs
released from jail,
avoidance from
punishment, the military,
may occur often after
a car accident when
no-fault insurance
is involved. This is
actually not considered
a psychiatric
illness and was not
included in the DSM-5.
And the DSM is
the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual
that lists many
of the psychiatric
conditions.
Case 15 is a 35
-year-old woman
who reports
feeling pins and
needles in her
hands and feet.
This was a close family
member of mine who
called me concerned
that she had a brain
stem tumor. She decided
to google her symptoms
and told me that if
it wasn't a brain
stem tumor, then she
believes that she has
MS because she happens
to be a physician.
She's preoccupied
with her condition
and began to
affect her life.
This was actually
illness anxiety disorder.
It's excessive
concern about having
or developing a serious
undiagnosed general
medical disease.
Previously, patients
were diagnosed with
what was called
hypochondriasis that
was in the DSM-IV-TR.
Patient has a
specific has a belief
that they have a
specific disease. It
is now called illness
anxiety disorder,
which is included
in the DSM-5TR.
Case 16 is a patient
sitting in the clinic
exam room. This is
a 35-year-old woman
who suddenly stares
off into the distance
and begins to furiously
kiss the cross
that's hanging from her
neck. It goes on for
two minutes. During
this time, she does
not respond to the
examiner's questions.
Slowly, she returns
back to her baseline.
This is an example of
a focal seizure with
discognitive features.
The seizures involve
abnormal electrical
impulses within the
cerebral cortex.
There's an alteration of
consciousness, which
occurs in a period of
confusion that follows
the event. It lasts for
one to three minutes
and may also consist
of automatism, such as
lip smacking, chewing,
swallowing, grimacing,
or stereotomies,
and it was formally
called complex partial
seizures. The treatment
for this is anti
-epileptic medication,
an EEG, an MRI with
seizure protocol help
to make this diagnosis.
Case 17 is a 50-year
-old woman who is
referred for evaluation
of a movement disorder.
When asked about
her troublesome son,
she lies down, turns
her head to the left,
and begins to shake
violently. This
continues for five
full minutes. When this
event is over, she gets
up and drives home.
This is a non-epileptic
or dissociative
seizure. It's
characterized by sudden and
time-limited disturbances
of motor, sensory,
autonomic, cognitive,
and or emotional
functioning that can
mimic epileptic seizures.
These events are not
caused by abnormal
brain activity but
rather by physical
or mental stress. It
may occur in a patient
who also has seizures.
This condition was
previously called
psychogenic seizures.
Now they're called non
-epileptic seizures.
The treatment for
this as psychotherapy.
Case 18 is a 56-year
-old woman who her
and many members of
her family do not
recognize other
people's faces. She only
recognizes people once
she hears their voice.
She was born with
an intact visual
cortex and did not
have any brain damage.
This is called
congenital prosopagnosia.
It is the inability
to recognize faces.
The patient is unable
to recognize close
friends and relatives
or pictures of
famous people. This
condition runs in families
and does not involve
a brain lesion.
Prosopagnosia may
occur as an acquired
condition, such as
due to bilateral
lesions of the
temporal occipital
area or as a
hereditary condition.
Case 19, a child
complained that
everything in the
room felt very small.
The mother
explained that the
child recently had
a viral infection.
so this is called alice
in wonderland syndrome
it's a perceptual
disorder that involves
brief transient episodes
of visual distortions
it can occur in
conjunction with viral
infections such as
epstein-barr which is the
most common when this
occurs objects or body
parts are perceived
as altered in various
ways and no permanent
brain abnormalities are
seen the causes of
alice in And the causes
of Alice in Wonderland
syndrome include other
infectious causes such
as varicella, H1N1,
coccyx virus,
typhoid fever, or
scarlet fever. It can be
caused by migraines,
psychiatric disorders,
including major depression
or schizophrenia,
epileptic seizures.
There's a list of
medications that can cause
this, including
topiramate, risperidone,
montelukast,
and some others.
CNS lesions that can
cause this include
infarct, tumor,
or hemorrhage. and
substances such as
*******, cannabis,
MDMA, ***, and
others can also cause
the Alice in
Wonderland syndrome.
Case 20 is a patient
who had a limb
amputation. Following
the amputation, he swears
that there's pain
where the leg was.
This is fairly common
in amputees and it's
called phantom limb
syndrome. There's painful
sensations which refer
to the missing limb
It could also
be a breast or
******. The
condition was first
described in the
16th century.
Wars and landmines
are responsible
for many of the traumatic
amputations
over the years.
Females and upper
extremity amputation
are at higher risk.
And mirror therapy
is used with a variety
of other options.
This is an
example of mirror
therapy, as you
can see here.
in summary the goal
is to distinguish
neurologic disorders
from psychiatric
disorders identify
when a patient is
causing harm to
himself or someone
else is harming them
i hope you've enjoyed
this thank you
for your attention